de retour à Paris Louis XIV remis sur
pied nadieux que pour marie-moncini et
pense avoir trouvé la femme de sa vie
les deux jeunes gens ne se quittent plus
et rêve de se marier on a souvent dit
que ça avait été comment dirais-je
platonique essentiellement platonique on
ne pourra pas monter de l'idée que
vif comme il était et chaude comme elle
pouvait l'être cette petite italienne il
ne se soit rien passé physiquement entre
eux c'est incontestable et ils vont
s'aimer c'est toi
vous me tutoyer
[Musique]
il est loin de se douter que la
politique va se mêler des affaires de
cœur
[Musique]
car la raison Premier ministre
Istre d'un
très beau et la jeune Marie va tomber de
haut
elle est convaincue qu'elle va devenir
reine bien entendu jusqu'à ce que tonton
Mazarin réagissent en disant mais enfin
il en est pas question le roi de France
ne va pas épouser une de mes nièces
comme ça ça ne va rien apporter au
royaume ça c'est le sens du royaume de
Mazarin qui envisage tout de suite des
mariages politiques destin de Louis XIV
était de se lier à une famille royale
étrangère et Marie Mancini n'avait pas
sa place au sein de ce dispositif
la rupture est inévitable
Marie Mancini est chassé de la cour
les adieu avec son bien-aimés le roi
sont déchirants
vous êtes le roi
et vous pleurez
[Musique]
vous avez 20 ans vous aimez une jeune
femme que vous trouvez splendide que
vous trouvez superbe et vous ne pouvez
pas rester avec elle pour raison d'État
c'est incompréhensible dans la tête d'un
jeune homme de 20 ans Louis XIV devient
Louis XIV quand il renonce à Marie
Mancini parce que il a compris que la
raison d’état lui interdit d'épouser
cette cette jeune fille il lui a promis
qu'elle deviendrait reine et il est
obligé évidemment de revenir sur sa
parole
Marie Mancini quitte la cour Louis XIV
doit se résoudre à épouser une autre
femme une certaine Marie-Thérèse
d'Autriche fille du roi d'Espagne une
jeune femme qu'il ne connaît pas qu'il
n'aime pas et qu'il n'aimera jamais tout
roi qu'il est il doit se conformer à la
raison d'État plus forte que les élans
du cœur
[Musique]
1660 c'est le mariage de Louis XIV et de
Marie-Thérèse d'Autriche à
Saint-Jean-de-Luz à la frontière
espagnole un mariage royal certes qui
celle la paix entre la France et
l'Espagne mais très vite l'infante
d'Espagne va comprendre que son rôle à
la cour sera pour le moins limité le
principal rôle d'une reine de France
pour Louis XIV est de donner à la
couronne des héritiers elle a un rôle
pardonnez-moi de potiche on lui demande
simplement d'être là car le roi
catholique se doit d'être marié dès le
départ la nouvelle reine Marie-Thérèse
ne fait pas vraiment l'unanimité